chili salad frosties baked potatoes
hamburgers with bacon with cheese biggie
fries biggie drinks
it's 1989 and this is an ad introducing
one of the first value menus hogwash
eight choices all under a buck 50 give
me a break value or for some restaurants
dollar menus are a group of items
designed to be the cheapest on the menu
value menus are really great when
consumers are feeling stressed out you
know we are back in a in a time of
consumer stress but recent inflation and
supply chain issues are changing them in
2021 u.s restaurant chains promoted
fewer than half the number of value and
combo meals that were promoted in 2016.
here's how they became popular and now
why there are fewer and more expensive
value menu options
wendy's and taco bell were the first to
launch their value menus in the late 80s
wendy's was called the super value menu
with nine items available for 99 cents
founder dave thomas introduced the menu
with ads like this so wendy's is
introducing a new super value menu oops
everything on it is at a special low
price value menus really did change the
game in far-reaching and long-lasting
ways so before the valley menus were
introduced you know what we were really
thinking about in a lot of ways were
these burger wars the burger wars broke
out in the 1970s with burger king and
mcdonald's going head-to-head to attract
customers but that changed in the 90s
when they noticed other competitors
value menus they realized that this was
an important strategy that these other
brands had pushed and they decided that
they needed to get into it in 2000
burger king highlighted the new cravers
menu with ads like this craving more
taste more variety all you need is 99
cents then mcdonald's debuted its menu
with former president donald trump
promoting a mcchicken sandwich or a big
and tasty for a buck a big and tasty for
just a dollar how do you do it what's
your secret
so fast forward into the later 2000s
there was times where restaurants were
focusing more on quality or their menus
or advertising new products to try to
keep consumers interested but when the
recession hit that's really when they
started getting back to basics and one
thing consumers really want from some of
these fast food chains is affordable
food take mcdonald's one dollar drinks
as an example around 2008 mcdonald's
started promoting one dollar cold drinks
with ads like this
with chain executives saying they helped
keep customers coming to the restaurants
during the recession
but to offer that for a dollar that
really is great messaging and you know
it makes you want to buy other stuff
right you you're buying this you know
salty fries or
or a savory burger and a soda naturally
goes along with that but recently some
companies have told shareholders they're
concerned about earnings part of that
concern is driven by inflation which hit
a 40-year high in june as fuel goes up
as labor goes up
as again these commodity prices go up
and selling this food
very cheaply for again often
not much profit if at all it becomes
really hard for these restaurants to
keep doing that mcdonald's said in july
they expect paper and food prices to
increase 12 to 14 percent from 2021
levels
and wendy's told investors in may that
its commodity costs were increasing
faster than expected they said
restaurant profits decreased in its
first quarter mostly due to price
increases for things like meats which
increased around eight percent from last
year
a wendy's spokeswoman said the company
still offers some long-running value
combos that predate the pandemic and
inflation concerns plus many restaurants
are raising menu prices to offset rising
costs for commodities like vegetable oil
you think about all those fries that are
frying all those onion rings i mean that
takes a lot of oil prices of oils have
increased due to multiple factors like
the war in ukraine which exports over 47
percent of the world's sunflower oil and
because of that the the cost of oil has
just skyrocketed prices of fats and oils
increased around 19 from last year so
what are restaurants doing about these
price increases
two popular approaches are to cut down
on portion sizes and raise prices
changes at burger king included lifting
price caps on value menu items and
reducing the number of nuggets in one
deal from 10 to 8. one term for it is
shrink-flation which is basically the
amount of food being offered to
customers in an individual serving is
less and again this is
a way for restaurants to try to offer
value still but without having to change
the actual menu price but saving a
little bit of money and hopefully
improving their profit a burger king
spokeswoman said the company doesn't
comment on sales or marketing strategies
domino's is reducing the number of
chicken pieces in its 7.99 deal from 10
to 8. domino's ceo said it made the
change in response to higher labor costs
and an increase in food costs the
company has also said prices on things
like menus offers and delivery fees this
quarter increased by nearly six percent
on average
anne mcdonald said in an earnings call
in july that obviously there are cost
pressures both on the commodity and
labor side but we have to balance that
with continuing to provide value for our
customers they also said in april that
u.s locations increased menu prices by
an average of eight percent in the first
quarter compared with last year's period
mcdonald's said that the value
initiatives are part of the company's
strategy and are collaborative between
mcdonald's and franchisees and that
franchisees set prices you know it's
really interesting because in terms of
consumer perception of these price hikes
when you talk to the companies
themselves
and when you look at their earnings
reports you know they're still seeing
strong sales
this has driven increased revenue for
some chains mcdonald's said that higher
prices and value menu offerings pushed
same store sales up around four percent
in the us from last year so i think for
a certain segment of customers value
menus are still going to be really
important and i think restaurants will
still offer those menus
but until inflation declines companies
will probably keep changing their value
menus which may mean fewer deals
[Music]